The kitchen of misery isn't just about what you put in your mouth, it's about what you deny your
body. And nothing denies the body more thoroughly than sleep. Oh, sleep is the great equalizer,
the one thing that could actually clear the fog from your mind. But we can't have that,
not when the alternative is a slow, deliberate erosion of clarity, a landscape where every
blade of grass is really a thorn and every shadow hides another what-if. This is the circadian
shuffle, a recipe for 24 hours of foggy resentment served with a side of self-inflicted dread.
It starts, as these things do, with the twilight scroll. Around 11.30 p.m., when your eyelids grow
heavy and your thoughts begin to drift toward the kind of rest that might actually help you,
you resist, you reach for the phone, not to call someone, not to read something meaningful. No,
you open a social media feed, and you scroll, and scroll, and scroll, until you find it, that one
post, that one life, that one person younger than you, achieving something you haven't, a promotion,
a milestone, a damn hobby you've been too exhausted to pursue. And there it is, the perfect fuel for the
fire you've been carefully tending. Then comes the blue light bath. You hold the phone close,
just four inches from your face, and you let the glow wash over you like a desert sunrise.
Your pineal gland, poor thing, doesn't stand a chance. It mistakes the artificial radiance for
daylight, and suddenly, your brain is convinced it's noon in the Sahara. No melatonin. No surrender.
Just another hour of wide-eyed, wired vigilance, because why rest when you could be feeling
something? Anything but peace. By midnight, the existential crisis hits. That familiar gnawing
in your gut, the one that whispers, you're failing. You always fail. You get up. You go to the kitchen.
You brew a cup of coffee espresso. If you're feeling particularly masochistic, and you sit down,
you open your bank statement. You stare. You convince yourself this is productivity, that you're
planning, that you're preparing. Meanwhile, your heart rate ticks up, your shoulders tense, and the
caffeine works its magic, turning your blood into liquid adrenaline, because misery tastes better
when it's jittery. Then, back to bed. But not to sleep. No. You've got work to do.
You take that old argument from 2014, the one you've been carrying around like a rusted anchor,
and you stir it back up. You refry it. You should have said this. You should have done that. Three
things. Then five. Then ten. You let it simmer until the clock hits 4.45 a.m., because by then,
the resentment has thickened into something rich and satisfying. A full dark brew of self-recrimination,
just the way you like it. And then, oh, then comes the sun. The sun, that traitor, rises. It peeks
through the curtains. It spills across your pillow. It dares you to wake up. But you don't. Not yet.
You hit snooze. Six times. Because the frantic rush of a day that starts with your alarm blaring
at 7 a.m.? That's not just a way to begin the day. That's a feature. Cortisol levels spike.
Adrenaline floods your system. Your brain, still half asleep, scrambles to keep up. And just like
that, you've set the stage for another masterpiece of self-sabotage. There's a note from the chef you
see. If, God forbid, you actually fall asleep before 1-9, don't panic. Just set an alarm for
3-cough, hi-m. Check your email. Let that work notification jolt you awake. Let it remind you
that, yes, the world is still spinning. And, yes, you are still failing to keep up. It's the perfect
garnish. A little something to make the ruin of your tomorrow taste just right.